Apple a supprimé l'encoche sur ses
iPhone 14 pro pour venir mettre dynamic
Island alors dynamic Island c'est quoi
c'est une espèce de petite bulle que
vous avez et qu'ils ont complètement
intégré d'un point de vue logiciel vous
allez pouvoir retrouver vos appels la
charge de votre smartphone vos airpods
un timer une alarme bref tout va se
passer ici dans cette dynamic Island
alors en fait ça permet quoi ça permet
de récupérer un petit peu d'écran
au-dessus vous avez toujours face ID
pour venir déverrouiller très facilement
je trouve que c'est pas mal plutôt bien
fait dites-moi ce que vous en pensez et
puis poursuivre toute la queue tech je
vous invite à venir vous abonner